already a large queue is building in the  capital with people being warned that  they could face a 30-hour wait to pay  their respects her majesty rained for 70  years  i can give for 24 hours at the very  front of the line is vanessa who arrived  on monday at 11 30 in the morning by  chance i found out the queue is going to  start here  original plan was wednesday morning but  then after finding out i thought i'm not  going to leave the position i just  wanted to be there people coming in  their thousands to wait uh to stand in  line uh to pay their respects  she's an incredible woman she'll be  oh god i'm not even from here but  i just feel like she's had a profound  impact on all of us and  it's part of history